it is 10
o'clock here I
am uh we are opening the hearing on all
of the retained bills the um the bill
commission bills and we are going to be
going into a recess so that our members
can clock us um considering how much we
discussed yesterday uh with the ranking
members so we will be in
recess till about
10:15 or
later
e
and join me for the pledge of allegiance
that we
begin I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for it stands one nation under
God indivisible with liberty and justice
for all
okay we are picking up again on our
continued hearings on the retained bail
bills and today we're going to be
addressing the subject of people who are
arrested while they are already on bail
for a previous
crime we have several proposals that
we've been working on that we're going
to discuss right now um the first
proposal with regard to someone who's
arrested wall on bail for a previous
charge what we've looked at um based on
all the uh testimony we've received
first of all that the public in general
is had enough of people being arrested
in this type of revolving door type of
situation um happening and it's not
necessarily the the very serious crimes
as um were contemplated in sever of the
bills we had like a list of 12 or 13
crimes these are the more um for lack of
a better term nuisance crimes the
shoplifting the trespassing the
disorderly person
repeatedly so what we are contemplating
is if you are arrested while on bail for
the first time you are picked
up we are talking about having the court
system through the bail Commissioners
use give the person a choice here's your
choice you've been arrested and violated
the terms of your first B bail which is
a new crime contempt of
court you may be
released if you so choose but as a
condition of that release you will wear
an electronic
monitor which will be placed on by the
bail commissioner
and he will or she will set the
conditions of that bail and what that
electronic monitoring system will be
monitoring with regard to your specific
situation or B you can decline the
electronic monitoring and you will
remain in jail until you see a
judge second offense if you get picked
up yet again while wearing the monitor
after you've been released again you
will be held until you see the
judge now as part of that we are
cognizant of the Court's ability and the
defense Department's ability to be able
to um conduct business on Saturdays at
some point in the future that may be
something we we have to look at
currently with the time frame money and
resources available to everybody
involved that's just not
feasible so as part of that and we'll be
discussing this next week more in depth
we're looking at implementing a
magistrate program where magistrates
will and I brought this up briefly
yesterday be a sounded to each county in
the state and they'll have um first line
supervis
supervisory um over the how many bail
condition uh bail Commissioners are in
their counties Etc they'll probably
coordinate um the issuance of these of
these um electronic monitoring devices
and the whole program will be left up to
the court um that's that's their
business we're not going to micromanage
it but as far as the weekends which is
what I'm want to address if you're
picked up on a
Friday um for one of these things you
and it's uh you will be
held up to 24 hours at which point you
will see a magistrate over the weekend
on a Saturday who will make the
determination whether or not your
dangerous Flight Risk or you should be
held um they are going to be no
different than the judge I mean excuse
me than the bail commissioner they're
not going to have any more Powers than
the bail commissioner with regard to the
bail um so it's not going to invoke all
the necessary um hearings and everything
of this nature it just means that you're
going to be held for this person who
will be um probably a JD someone more
qualified than the um average bail
commissioner is again that'll be set in
the legislation that we discuss next
week so for today that is what we are
proposing um with regard to the arrest
and rearrest all on bail and I would
open it up to discussion from the
members representative Stone thank you
uh in regards to the term magistrate
have you set a definition of a
magistrate is going to be someone who
has to be admitted to the New Hampshire
bar we have not yet set that definition
but that is one of the things that we
are working on as far as what the
qualifications would have to be thank
you and as we I I would welcome your
input because we're at that stage where
we're trying to figure out what that
is but with anything with regard to the
arrest and
rearrest represent
Muse I think one of the dilemmas uh uh
facing us is um uh with issues like this
um there are so many factors that come
into play um
essentially I think we're in a
situation where I think we can
substantially uh reduce the risk uh you
know of the public being harmed by a
person who's uh out on bail uh who
should not be on the other hand I don't
think we're ever going to be be in a
situation where we can 100%
guarantee uh you know uh uh that all of
us will be safe so I I think there are
reasonable measures and I think this is
one of them um electronic monitoring as
an option uh is something that will uh
provide uh more guard rails um and it's
an alternative to incarceration it's
however not without its problems and uh
I think there are issues that we we're
going to have to work through in terms
of in terms of the cost uh who does the
monitoring um how exactly bail
Commissioners are you know you know
implement this and are trained to do to
do it um but the bottom line is what it
does is it it does put more
accountability in the system it puts
more oversight into the system uh it's
something that the public uh seems to be
asking for for and it is um one of the
it's a less restrictive option than than
simply holding people in jail pre-trial
detention uh and it puts people in a
situation where even if they've
committed a second crime a lot of times
those second crimes are still relatively
minor uh and even though people have
been accused of crimes and sometimes
even even accused of two crimes um we're
not
always there you know frequently there
are situations where people are actually
in the unconvicted of neither
crime so having uh an additional tool in
the toolbox uh you know to to better
ensure that that people you know that
people do appear
um you know to me seems like something
that is uh is worth uh exploring more uh
and potentially trying
thank you and um to just to add on to
that point um it will be significant
there is going to be cost and there is
going to be a fiscal note but I dare say
it will be um it will be much less than
holding people would cost um if they're
arrested on the first time after um
they've been bailed because that will
drive up exponentially the number of
people who are held and um the cost will
be very very high so I feel like this
will be a lower cost to the state and
the counties um actually it shouldn't be
any cost to the counties where the
counties would bear the full cost of
people being held and we heard from the
counties that they just don't have the
the the finances or the the wherewithal
to to be able to staff that type of a
increase so that's and also keeping in
mind this is a choice we're offering
people a choice they don't have to take
electronic monitoring if they feel it
violates their privacy or their rights
they're free to to sit and wait for the
judge to hear their their
case uh representative
Stone thank you is there going to be a
recovery cost uh for the individual if
convicted we we're not sure yet because
we don't know the cost um what it's
going to cost at this point um we could
leave it open to the court whether or
not they assign a fine or a uh some type
of recovery um for the cost of the
expense of the monitoring the difference
the difference
is it's pre-conviction so I think it's
even if they do end up being ultimately
convicted I don't know that it'll be
difficult to to um to recover that
amount I don't know we can discuss that
with the court and see if that's
something they're interested in in thank
you yeah definitely worth worth raising
um representative Murray um I was
thinking along the same vein like I know
um the folks who came to talk with us
from pre-ra services and stuff talked
about how they would um charge the
people that were being monitored for the
cost of monitoring them daily um but I
don't know if it's better to do it as a
recovery if they're you know convicted
but those were
pre-trial represent Stone now just to a
followup to that the probation and
parole department already utilize
electronic monitoring and I believe
there is a service fee for them being
out on release I guess that's an Avenue
that's already been set that's why I'm
looking at new process is served and the
conviction is had that maybe there is a
recovering mechanism that could help
offset the cost of the taxpayers I agree
um I I I agree um within the the usual
parameters of indigency or whatever if
it the person is able to repay then they
should and we'll leave it up to the
courts about how they would like to
reclaim that money I think
representative
Muse and one of one of the things um
that we've run into as we've done some
research on this is uh there are
alternatives to uh to things like
electronic ankle bracelets so there are
apps that some jurisdictions are using
one of the things that we've learned uh
during testimony in the various work
sessions that we have is that
surprisingly there are a lot of people
uh even even homeless folks um uh who
have who have uh cell phones um uh
whether or not uh these apps you know
will work on the particular phones that
people have uh is is another question
but increasingly there are uh there
appear to be options um uh in addition
to just conventional ankle bracelets so
as we as we write the statute one of the
things that we uh we've talked about
doing is actually writing it in a way
that describes the
functionality of the monitoring device
without necessarily specifying which
monitoring device um is uh is
acceptable I think actually that's um
that's a very good point and we are
going to um as broadly defined
electronic monitoring as possible so
that we don't have to come back and
broaden it later as technology gets um
advances faster and
faster we want to um describe what we're
trying to accomplish with the electronic
monitoring and leave it to the court to
decide which method of Technology they
use going forward so that if such a time
comes when they are able to use a
different technology maybe software or
what have you um or combination of any
of them they have the bandwidth or the
the allowance in the legislation to do
that so I think that's that's a very
good point further discussion anyone
else representative Harry
gther we also talked a little bit about
um on the first arrest if we realize
that that person is um let's say um
doing drugs or mentally ill um at that
time trying to refer them to for some
type of help with whatever is determined
at that
time yes we did discuss that and we are
going to put that in what what it what
we're contemplating is so when a when
someone is first arrested regardless of
the
crime there are Services generally
available so for example if someone is
arrested for shoplifting because they
say I I have to have food for my family
um you know the state is not without a
heart so what we are going to do is
ensure that that person gets referred to
Services where they could get food so
that if they're picked up again for
shoplifting for food after they've been
given a referral for services we know
okay you had a a chance to get that and
you were offered that so we're going to
mandate that Services be referred on
first arrest for anything that is
related tangentially to the crime
they're arrested for if they're arrested
for drugs referral to rehabilitation
services or what have you same thing
goes for food anything like that where
there are services available to make
sure that the people are connected with
them as soon as
possible did that cover that Lindon
yes anyone else representative Reed you
seem to have some some uh reservations
so um if they're referred for services
um will they still be um you know have
to see the judge and and okay this is
this is just a um here you are you're
under arrest here's your bail and by the
way here all right so it's not in place
of or L of or anything like that it's
just making sure that that people are
made aware of services that are
available all right thank you often
times I think what happens now some of
the bail Commissioners are very good at
saying okay look you know you could go
here but some of them may not some of
them may not know and so often times
people are arrested didn't let go and
they're just right back where they were
with no idea how to contact services so
we're going to um mandate that people
are at least giv referrals to services
that are available I thank
you I do have another question but I
think I need the officer to answer this
for
me sure um if he's willing to testify
you
willing I saw your hand Professor Sher
yeah
good morning good
morning so gown so are you Hills be
Hillsboro County right okay question for
you okay do you do you say as golf town
do you know the different services that
might be in the
area as a police officer yeah I I guess
it's it's kind of a broad qu okay say um
someone that has mental illness do you
know where you might be able to refer
that person or someone seems to be on
drugs or alcohol do you know where yeah
we have the mobile crisis team which is
out a greater uh greater manchest of
mental health um so we know we we we
have connections with them all right
that was one of the questions that we
had because we realized that uh
Hillsboro doesn't have the pre-service
type um accountability as some of the
other locations that came and spoke
before us the other counties came and
like Rockingham has a pretty decent
Hillsboro does not exactly but for the
most part the officers do know of the
different types of services
possibly yeah we we
we often deal with uh the mobile crisis
team with great Manchester mental health
for mental health um issues
okay and I think we're we're not
contemplating putting that on the police
anyway I think we're going to um we're
going to put that on the courts to make
sure that the people are notified at the
services in the area um versus the
police I think we um we talked about on
first arrest yeah but they still have to
get bailed so a bail commissioner could
through the court provide uh whatever
documentation the Court gives them to
hand out for that area because I don't
want to put that funding cost to produce
all that information on the police
departments um if we're going to pay the
courts anyway any other questions for
the officer representative Stone please
thank
you in your experience do you find that
these proposals would meet the needs to
try to address the Nu and arrests that
maybe your department or similar
Department's
experience the the electronic monitoring
specifically it's part of the bill proc
um I mean it's something um you know
right now they're just they're just
walking out of the PD they're walking
right out the door um domestic violence
specifically um they're they're just
getting PR bail and walking out um and
you know I I prosecute also I'm an
attorney I prosecute for the PD
and the the amount of failure to appear
is at court through the roof and it's
just wasting time and if they were on
the monitor you'd know right where to go
pick them up if they failed to appear it
yeah I got a stack of failure to appears
every every court appearance I made
yeah and I believe that as part of the
monitoring we're going to um as we write
it we'll leave it open for software or
whatever even perhaps through the
monitor they can be buzzed to notify to
your courts coming up I mean there's all
kinds of technology so we want to make
sure that a we know where they are if
they're not supposed to be somewhere so
if you have a defendant who's been
arrested for trespassing at a store and
part of his bail conditions are not to
go back to that store you'll know
through the monitoring that he's back at
that store and yet again violated his
bail conditions and you'll know right
where they are to to go pick them up so
do you feel like that um is a step in
the right direction towards helping yeah
I do and I think uh specifically on the
um you know I go back to the domestic
violence again where there's a no
contact order um I think that will
protect the have some protection for the
victim if the that defendant is out
there um because they're often times um
in violation of that no contact order
and the victim may be afraid to call the
police because he or she doesn't know
what's going to happen to set him off or
her off again right so the monitoring
would notify um law enforcement that the
person is again within the Geo fenced
area that they're not supposed to be
near that victim I'm not
too I'm not too versed on how these
bracelets work and how we would the
police would have access to them but
yeah the the court um what we're
contemplating is that um the court would
have to enter a contract with a company
that monitors in the monitoring agency
would notify whoever the court tells to
notify so if the court says as part of
your bail conditions you are not to go
within a th000 ft of this person's
residence or the police will be notified
that company would then notify the local
police that that person had indeed
violated the conditions of that release
yeah that that would be excellent so
with regard to um further representative
Stone's question to you and as far as
being arrested and held if you are
arrested yet again after unveiled do you
feel like that is um a beneficial
proposal I I do I do and you
know for a couple reasons is you know
the safety of the public and and for the
assuring they're going to show up in
court if
they're out on bail and still committing
more crimes likely they're not going to
show up for court either yeah agree okay
any further questions for the
officer thank you
Captain um Professor Sher you you had
raised your
hand oh I'm sorry what represent muray
did you have a question for the officer
no not a question thank you I just feel
like I have to name that we heard a lot
during testimony about the lack of
services available so you know even
though we're going to require bail
Commissioners to you know inform people
about available Services there might not
be like services available to refer
people to um representative um rhs thank
you Mr chairman in in reference to
representative Murray's
comment you know we heard from a few of
the counties that do already have these
PR trial services and one of the things
that I mentioned and I realized that I'm
preaching to quat to the choir with all
of you but I would just like to stress
to everybody here if your county does
not have these prechal Services you are
in a very very unique situation to
approach your County Commissioners and
get the conversation started I if it's
happening in other counties it can
happen in all 10 and we have to be the
ones to make it make it happen and if
you need to reach out to the other
counties to have them come to your
county I I I guarantee you chesher
County would do that and that's going to
be on all of us to make that be become a
reality also I think that um as we
discussed one of the bills that we have
we are going to repurpose to task the
existing inter Branch commission that
worked on Bill in 2018 that commission
still exists and we're going to ret ask
that commission to come up with um
legislation and ideas to Institute
Statewide um pre-trial Service as one of
their mandates so that issue is not
going to go away when we're done with
this professor Sher um a couple points
about uh what you've all been talking
about and I I appreciate the
committee's um efforts to sort through
this in a way that is productive just
briefly on the services issue I think uh
uh in terms of how
how uh that recommendation is drafted
and put in the legislation I Council
very strongly against putting the burden
on a individual on a defendant to get
Services when depending on the area it
may be very very uncertain whether those
services are available so I don't want
to say to uh you know an individual you
need to go get these services and
because they're in xounty those Serv are
available the recommendation was going
to be specific in other words you um XYZ
um NGO is available for you to go talk
to and they it won't be just go find
some services and and and and in terms
of services you know as representative
roads knows well um pre-trial Services
programs are funded by the county and I
know cheser and straford County have
more money because they're house housing
uh federal inmates and I think that
makes it very helpful for them uh
whereas you know Coos County and Carol
County or in different circumstance um
in terms of uh electronic monitoring uh
you know I'm upset two minds one um I
think uh giving electronic monitors to
everyone could be over Brad I mean
there's just some crimes just not going
to make any difference the crime doesn't
relate to trying to understand where
they are uh that said uh I understand
the dynamic that the committee has uh
has laid out and it allows for somebody
to be be released and so I I I get that
the one of the two key things that I
think are really
important while the if somebody is found
if the
third-party Agency for whom the court
contracts uh learns that a person has
violated the strictures of the
electronic money they've gone somewhere
they shouldn't have gone or what or they
haven't showed up for court um and they
notify the court uh and the police they
that the court notifies the police to go
pick that person up I don't I think it
needs to be explicit in the legislation
that the police do not have access to
the all the electronic monitoring data
on that person from the time the monitor
was in place to the time they were
picked up I don't think we should create
a circumstance where the electronic
monitoring system is used as another
investigative tool for the police I I I
think it needs to be narrowly written so
that the the the only information the
police get from the the third party via
the court is where this person is now
and that's all they have access to uh
they don't get to look at all the data
and figure out where um uh you know
other things use for investigative
purposes I think that's very important
um let me just address that before you
move to the next Point um I think that
that um that that does raise a good
point I think that whatever in the
statute it it will say that the court
will authorize the information to the
police department for violations of the
terms of bail in other words if the term
of bail is you don't go here and you go
here that information can be related to
the police department but the blanket
you know where this person is all day
long will not that's why we're not
having the police monitor it we're using
a third party I do believe however that
if a proper warrant is obtained it
should be made available um if if a
search warrant is authorized and they're
in uh I mean that's a difficult
situation uh I I have difficulty with
that to be honest with you but we're not
going to put it in the thing but um I
imagine it'll get raised at some point
in the future in the future
um second um
I I think it's a big mistake to create a
circumstance any circumstance in which
the individual upon whom the electronic
monitoring is uh placed
pays at the time after the fact people
in you know the large majority of people
involved in the criminal justice
system um don't have
money um as I've said in all sorts of
different context they don't even have
the luxury of living paycheck to
paycheck and you know every little bit
is a problem you know uh the for example
the court coming after them for bail
commissioner fees the penalty assessment
that's used to fund certain things um
there's all sorts of fees put aside
getting fined put aside if you're
convicted having to reimburse the state
at a certain rate for uh for the council
that you got Council that you got cuz
you're poor uh and and and now you have
to reimburse the state um there's all
sorts of these fees separate from fines
and restitution that pile up and um I
just you
know I don't like the idea that we're
just adding another fee you know 50
bucks for everybody on this committee is
a lot different than 50 bucks for a
homeless person and and you know I
I I don't think they should be punished
for having electronic
monitor we will take that under
advisement um I I would differ a little
bit I think that if they have the
wherewithal to pay they should be made
to pay if they're Indigent they should
not um we shouldn't automatically put it
on the taxpayer who also is being buried
in taxes and fees on a daily bases as
well and committed no crime so um but I
I I do take your point and I think
indent people obviously will will say if
you're indent you're indent and you
cannot get blood from a stone so um but
if someone does have the wherewith all
the pay I do not see why the taxpayer
shouldn't get
reimbursed um un and and I understand uh
uh the chair's perspective understanding
that the court system will say great
thanks another time I've got to figure
out whether this person has the ability
to pay or not could that not be done as
part of their um determination of
whether or not they get
Council in
theory I think I'm going to leave it um
that it's broad enough for the court to
make the decision if they are already
doing a determination of Indy for
whether or not they can get councel I
think at the same time that can say well
if you can't afford councel you can't
afford monitoring and that yeah the
um no go on the the the the difficulty
there
is to be
blunt the huge majority of Judges say
well affording not being able to afford
Council not being able to afford 5,000
bucks or a th000 bucks for a council or
10,000 bucks is different than not being
able to afford 50 bucks I think every
judge that I've talked to um will say
everybody can afford 50 bucks you know
it's that's that's my problem and it's
just the it's the accumulation of 50
Buck amounts that that do some people in
what if we specifically tie it to um
eligibility for Council if you are
determined to be um eligible for public
Council you are also determined not to
required to reimburse for the I'd feel a
lot better about that thank
you representative is waving his hand I
don't think he's just waving at me I
think he
may just
clarification would the uh first time
individual being bailed be an automatic
requirement for the electronic
monitoring or be optional it's optional
they can stay in jail if they want
that's I just wanted to clarify that
yeah yeah my understanding was the the
electronic monitoring was that the first
time somebody is arrested oh but it's
their choice that's not true what no no
no it's it's the first time arrested
while on bail for another off yeah
that's what that's what I don't I don't
think we have the money to put it on
everybody um but no that the first
arrest while on bail they have an option
take the take the monitoring or stay
with us and the next time that option is
not available and just I think this is
my last Point pick up on something
representative Muse was talking about
you know I I think some on the committee
know there's been some very valuable
studies done at least a couple done
about uh having a system set up where
you can text individuals that their
court date is coming up yeah um there's
really good research that's been done
and and and the court system did a pilot
program out in Rochester that they got
some good results from and then Co the
pandemic hit and they had to unwind it
and they still want to do it but they
don't have the money to do it I would
love to as uh the uh as the companies
are being investigated or the means of
doing electronic monitoring is
investigated you know I think it would
be very very helpful if there was a
requirement that they had an ability to
notify uh the individual who has the
electronic monitor at their court dates
coming up it's like a two
you know you you you you reduce failures
to appear and you have the other
benefits that the committee is looking
for for electronic monitoring I agree
and um we are going to put that in there
that's why I want to craft the
definition of electronic monitoring so
broadly that the court can use and
request funding for um any type of
technology that appears that's
successful to to help ensure people's
appearance and and their good
behavior thank you um you lied didn't
you I did lie but well I didn't lie I'm
a law professor so I have the right to
go on
forever he made it funny you
did
um a reference to mobile crisis units
I'm very familiar with mobile crisis
units because we've been working very
closely um in psmith the police
commission of which I'm a member has
been working very closely with seos
mental health and uh members of the
police department and others uh to
facilitate the use of seos the seos
mental health uh Coss mobile crisis unit
what they're for is they're
not really
for somebody's in court and the judge
can refer them to the mobile crisis unit
what they're for is to be way too acute
they're for crisis yeah um that is uh
either the mobile pric unit or the
dispatcher for the police department
gets a call saying
from uh say a family member that my uh
spouse is in seems to be in a mental
health crisis uh there'll be an initial
uh back and forth questioning uh of the
person calling in to determine whether
there is uh a realistic uh possibility
of danger to uh anyone um whether
weapons are involved or anything like
that if not then in the first instance
uh the dispatch
will send uh uh will contact the mobile
crisis unit to go to that location which
involves mental health professionals it
doesn't involve uniform police officers
showing up the point is they're not a
service that you refer they're not a
service uh that the court can refer
people to gotcha I think that um it'll
behoove the court to um to put out the
word that if you would like to have your
services offered to um defend ants
please let us know and we will pop
related a sheet of people who can be
contacted and I think that'll be an
excellent exercise with the courts
excellent thank you representative uh
Muse as we write the legislation one of
the things that may be important is
making sure
that we put some guard rails around the
use of the electronic monitoring data
and and the reason that I say that is it
because uh in Massachusetts there's
already been uh there's there's actually
already been a case where where the
Supreme Court there has ruled that um uh
essentially what the case involved was
um the police looking at monitoring data
across a large number of people who had
monitoring bracelets to see if any of
the people being monitored were in were
in the vicinity of a robbery that took
place uh as it turns out yes one of them
was in the v was in the vicinity uh and
was arrested and they actually
disallowed
that uh that uh uh particular arrest and
uh and the reason uh they said is that
going forward um the Commonwealth has to
demonstrate on the particular facts of
each individual case that warrantless
monitoring is reasonable to justify the
attachment of a GPS ankle bracelet so
one of the things that you
know one one of the things I think that
we that we need to consider is um in
this state we have a court system that's
especially um I think that probably
guards privacy rights uh maybe even more
carefully than Massachusetts does uh and
it's just something I think that we need
to be aware of as we put this put this
together that um that
establishing a blanket requirement
um may get us into legal and
constitutional issues down the road I
don't know what what would your opinion
be on that um
you're you know you're going to get me
going again but
um I apologize representative roades um
in 2018 the New Hampshire legislature
and the voting public passed a new
Constitutional Amendment that said uh uh
uh an an individual's right to be free
from government that an individual's
right to be free from governmental
intrusion on personal and private
information is natural essential uh and
inherent that is basically an
information privacy Constitutional
Amendment Massachusetts doesn't even
have that and there that opinion came
out that way it's a new Constitutional
Amendment that is still early and courts
haven't been interpreting it but having
been the author of that Constitutional
Amendment uh you know I think it's a
very expansive language and and it's
going to protect privacy rights in New
Hampshire as to personal or private
information more than any other state
does I mean it there's no other state
that has that so I think you know
the the electronic monitoring issue and
police having access even through a
search warrant to that data is is going
to be a a big issue um and I just I
don't intend to right um that they can
have access to a search warrant I
anticipate at some point someone is
going to apply for a search warrant and
try to get it and we will leave it up to
the courts to interpret the the um
constitutionality that in light of the
new Amendment so I think that they um
they need to tell us what they think of
it and but as far as um letting that
information representative Muse and your
point is is well taken and I don't
anticipate allowing broad access I think
only notifications will be be violations
of bail conditions that were set and
that should suffice for what we're
remember we have to keep in mind what
our goal is to ensure that someone
complies with the conditions of their
bail since they apparently didn't to be
arrested yet again so the only
information that should be shared is
when there is a violation of the bail
and specifically that information only
and and
and they it's not mandated they do have
the choice to say I don't want it and
stay in jail and I would specifically uh
ask that in in the legislation in that
regard the only information being shared
is the location of the violation rather
than broadly anything more broad oh yeah
yeah I well I couldn't see there'd be no
uh probative value in giving them the
whole days worth all they need to know
is when the violation occurred and where
yep agreed representative Pratt we went
over texting the person that uh a court
date is curring ing I've never been
arrested so I don't know do they get a
letter that says they have a court
date uh they are no in the better courts
they are
told when their court date is uh
depending uh a lot of people don't hear
that given the stress that they're under
in that
circumstance um uh and and and I believe
they I'm not the best person to talk to
but I believe they are uh provided with
a letter but there's some people who
don't don't
have an address at which they pick up
mail okay I'd be in favor of the text in
addition to a letter but not in place of
a
letter yeah the second part of my
question is
um wouldn't a test for indigen CB they
can afford a phone and service I know
people that work for a living that can't
afford a phone and but they're not
injured in let me just answer that if I
could um the federal government now
gives away phones um so um I don't know
that your friends would qualify because
they do work so that's that's a bigger
discussion for another body I think um
but yeah they all have phones um and if
they don't it's probably because they
need um other services because they are
not aware of the fact that the
government is giving away phones um I
was not aware of that the government oh
yeah yeah they do um any any further no
thank you okay oh you I'm sorry did
you oh hello did you want to say
something absolutely please please make
space good morning good morning um so
I'm Sarah Rothman I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire public
defender um I just wanted to to make sh
two short points one is um I and I don't
hear that this is being said today but I
just moving forward I I with regard to
electronic monitoring sometimes as these
programs evolve it requires the
defendant to have an address um that you
you won't qualify for electronic
monitoring unless you have a home
address um and so I would like to urge
the committee not to adopt any
legislation that would exclude probably
the very people that were trying to
capture um the people who struggle with
homelessness um maybe not a lot of them
full on homelessness but some of them
just transients um you know staying here
for a few weeks and there for a few
weeks um and so I I just don't want to
go down that slippery slope that we
often see with electronic monitoring um
that the very people who would benefit
most for it end up not qualifying for it
um the the other point I wanted to make
um is to urge the committee to consider
in terms of the the sort of outline that
that you've presented with you know if
the first time you were arrested while
out on bail you get this choice for
electronic monitoring or hold I would
urge the committee to consider um kind
of saying that that is for if you're
rearrested for you know a felony um
offense um to kind of craft it more
specifically than just any offense while
you're out on bail and potentially if
there are you know misdemeanor level
offenses particularly domestic violence
related offenses that you did want to
enumerate that you be more specific than
just kind of any arrest um while you're
out on bail um because the volume and I
I know kind of here and lies the point
right like that that this is a large
volume of people and that is what the
committee is is hoping to address um so
I am cognizant of that but at the same
time it's a large volume of people that
you are talking about like it is it is a
large volume of people um and I think as
Professor Sher has indicated not all of
those people even law enforcement would
agree you know would benefit from
electronic monitoring um and so as you
draft legislation I would urge you to
consider you know being specific about
what level of offense or what categories
of offenses um this would trigger and
and to your point here in Eli the
problem the the the reason we're
actually here in my opinion more so than
all these serious crimes is these
repetitive crimes um that are low-level
um trespass trespass trespass um
shoplift shoplift shoplift and if we say
okay only felonies they're going to keep
walking out the door um and some point
and and maybe more than anything we're
trying to force the court to address
this and say you know fix this we we
cannot just keep turning these people
loose to come back come back before you
the um police departments aren't goalies
just kicking people back into play we
have to find a way to address it um and
as much as I I would like to narrow it
and I will contemplate and take your
your um testimony under advis and I just
we we're struggling with a way to do
that which still does what the public is
demand we do it's we're kind of caught
between a rock and a hard place but
we're still we're still thinking and if
you have ideas yeah I'm happy to hear
them representative Reed thank you just
a basically a comment um I we were on
the um adult uh parole board study
committee and they found that you know
the high utilizers were the ones that
were two and a half times more likely to
be booked for for you know infractions
um and five or more entrances on average
beside the nonh high utilizer so I think
this would really impact that the people
were trying to to reach the
most so I think at the end of the day
and I can speak for just about everyone
in here the the problem is the lack of
of
resources
that address what is causing these
people to offend defend defend um and
the only way we're going to get there is
to take a Step In One Direction and um
we're going to revitalize that study
committee commission and mandate that
they find an answer to that um be it
Statewide pre-trial something so that we
can intervene before these patterns of
arrest keep
continuing anything else any questions
just briefly kind of on that point in
terms of creating a flyer of sorts to be
handed out by bail Commissioners um the
public defender is more than happy to be
involved in that process we have social
workers on staff who already have those
kinds of materials you know that we give
to our clients and so we're happy to
share and collaborate on that excellent
thank you thank you we will um we will U
look at putting that in there that
there's a coordination between various
entities representative rhods thank you
Mr
chairman the this is probably not going
to be a very popular thing and I
apologize upfront but
listen
we are not going to be able to make
everybody happy you know I don't I don't
agree with my husband 100% of the time
and I think what we have to realize
is if you are rearrested while you're
already on bail that that itself is a
crime and we're trying really hard to
keep people out of jail but we we can't
want to keep people out of jail more
than they want to be kept out of jail
and you know there's a difference
between an excuse and a reason and has
to be some accountability right and we
as a society are taking a lot of
accountability with all the programs
that we're trying to do with coming up
with this you know this option other
than
incarceration
and we can't we can't fix every social
problem right that these are things that
are starting in the
home and you know here we are trying to
deal with it so I think everybody what I
would like is everybody to take a step
back and realize we're we're we're not
all going to be happy and what we've
come up with in this committee is more
than anything anybody else
has and I I think we just all need to
focus on
that thank you I think it's worth noting
um that that that that's very accurate
but at the same time um people in this
room know that they're there's two
societies and most people don't realize
it but there are two societies there's
us
um who are here functioning and and
rational and we we plan vacations and we
plan for our retirement and there's
another Society within our society that
lives minute to minute dayto Day meal to
meal and they just don't have the
ability or capability to to understand
and make those kind of decisions so when
you and I are faced with a choice of
should I do this or should I not we
think out the ramifications whereas they
think well I'll still get the meal and
I'll deal with that later so I think
that we have to always keep in mind that
not everyone operates on the same plane
of um
of responsibility as they should just to
to oh sorry go ahead represent
Murray
um I I definitely agree we're not going
to come up with something that
everybody's going to be 100% on and I
think we're doing a good job
compromising so far and I appreciate all
of you in in this process um I did want
to say
um I think one misdemeanor in particular
that I have a hard time like seeing
being impacted by this is trespassing
because of the amount of houseless
people that have no option but to
trespass um you know whether that's
staying in a public park over the night
or you know being on a sidewalk um and I
just don't think that you know holding
those people and jail or giving them
electronic monitoring is going to stop
them from something that they're doing
because of their circumstances that
they're in so maybe if there's like
maybe if we're not um you know saying
specific um offenses that are going to
be that this is going to apply to then
maybe we can say certain offenses that
this is not going to apply to um I know
maybe not everyone will feel the same
way but it feels like difficult to
punish people for something that they
don't really have a choice in especially
if you know it's in an area where there
isn't a shelter or any place for them to
stay
um yeah that's just a concern of mine
thank you and that's that's a worthy
concern
um at the same time those are the the
the the store owners who are calling
saying you know this person's back in my
doorway again because there might be
heat coming up from the sidewalk there
um so it's it's difficult um I think we
have to ensure that where there are
services available for people shelters
Etc that the the they're made aware of
it and perhaps even you know given
Transportation there if possible um
versus just cut loose again and say now
don't trespass again um and I'm not
without although I I wonder with winter
coming if there some of them aren't
better off being able to have a place to
stay then then being sent back out into
the cold representative Stone thank you
uh one of the things that we always seem
to forget to mention is the victims and
a lot of these crimes do have victims uh
some of them do not but a majority of
them do and we we very rarely speak of
victims in this committee and one of the
things we're trying to balance out I
think is weighing out do process uh
presumption and innocence while also
respecting the victim's rights
trespassing can have a victim or cannot
have a victim I think it's injurious if
we decide to say well for trespassing
we're going to skip it all together but
we're going to go to uh shoplifting uh
some other minor misdemeanor offenses
misdemeanor offenses felony offenses are
classified for a reason I don't think we
should pick and choose choose which ones
we're going to enforce which ones we're
not going to enforce no I I think that
first of all to to your first comment um
the reason that we have narrowed it down
to these things and we've said okay we
have no tolerance on after your second
arrest um and and frankly that you have
a choice to wear the monitor or be
incarcerated is because of the victims
that's why we're doing this um in
trespassing as I said with regard to the
store owner generally does have a victim
whether or not it impacts them you know
someone who has a a storage facility
isn't as impacted as someone who's
trying to run a business but they're
still a victim and it's their privacy
and their property so I I I think that
we're going to try to balance that um
that's why I'm putting such an emphasis
on making sure that people are connected
with services at the time of the first
arrest so if they say hey I'm homeless
well we have a shelter here um that's
available and you can stay there um
versus verus just saying okay we'll back
outside don't go back there again um but
I agree about not picking offenses
representative Reed thank you we've all
society's always had the marginal um
people that that struggled with things
um it just seems to have exploded
exponentially so back in the the day we
used to have higher standards you know
that PE and people you set the bar High
people will try to achieve it you set
limits people will try and I think we
need to get back to that for Public
Safety we need to set the bar higher for
people to meet um and not just uh you
know give them a free run all the time I
I agree um and I'd agree wholeheartedly
if we could reach into society and take
all the fenel out um but until we can
we're not dealing with um people who are
able to set a higher standard for
themselves because they're addicted and
and to Sure join the conversation um to
with apologies to representative roads
um
the I always kind of seiz up when we
talk about the way things used to be
Grime rate in New Hampshire is
significantly lower after baill reform
than it was before baill reform so I I I
just want to put this in context this is
not this is not a matter of this never
seen before crime wave taking over New
Hampshire because of Bale reform I know
this committee by and large understands
that uh but I think the general public
doesn't understand it and I think what's
good about where we are now is in
addition to crafting domestic violence
laws and other uh other laws that pay
attention to uh the victims or the
alleged victims in cases we also looking
at the people in that second society
that the chair refers to who in in many
ways are as much victims uh uh as uh the
victims of a specific crime in terms
of um the failures of society to create
the set of Social Services that can that
can that can uh address the issues and
you know the the challenge for this
committee which fortunately I don't have
but the challenge for this committee is
to not impose too many of the
imperfections of this two Society world
not impose responsibility for those too
much of it on uh criminal defendants and
uh make us feel better that we're
dealing with the problem but we're not
actually uh dealing with those people
were imposing uh things on them so
that's you know I in deference to
representative Rosel shut up now thank
you
um representative wheeler you Mr
chairman I just want to say I'm
surprised to hear you paraphrasing
Martin Luther King and talking about two
Americas but it's true there's America
of wealth and prosperity and opportunity
and there's an America of living minute
to minute and and on the street and and
without and uh I think that problem is
much larger and much steeper than the
New Hampshire criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee can necessarily
deal with um and as much as we
as legislators in a broader sense should
absolutely try to push for those more
Social Services I think what we can do
in this committee is just ensure that
the criminal justice system is actually
a system uh and functions in a in a
proper way and I think the compromise of
electronic monitoring in a
constitutional way that appropriately uh
addresses what we're seeing here in
people being rearrested on bail without
throwing them and locking away the key
in the prison is an appropriate
compromise and I'm appreciative of your
work and representative goth right's
work on this end and getting us to this
point and emphasizing that we need and
representative
roads I
[Laughter]
am I am and getting us to this point and
I and I appreciate your emphasis on the
social services as well I am because I
think that's where we need to be going
and and the criminal justice committee
despite the fact that we can't deal with
every issue I I think has done a really
uh decent job in ensuring that we take a
huge step forward and getting us to
solving some of these issues so I
appreciate that thank you um I I you
should not be surprised however I uh I
have read Dr King and I have my great
respect for his work um I I I think that
you know there's an old saying every
when you're a hammer everything is a
nail and we are a criminal justice
committee not a social services
committee and we are trying to deal with
um issues that really um a lot of them
are social issues and not criminal
justice issues so we have to be very
careful to try and not deal with social
issues as crimes so we're it's it's it's
a very fine line we're walking to try
and at keep the public safe um ensure
that victims of crime are see Justice at
the same time not punish people for the
the society that we created for them to
live in so um we're working on it one
day at a time representative Stone thank
you one of the questions I have is you
bring up your data from 2018 and how we
have reduction in crime does any of that
studies indicate the deficiencies of law
enforcement agencies been able to
recruit hire and retain police officers
obviously less police officers means
less on the roadless uh crime that
they're actually arresting on the the
data I I'm referring to is FBI data
um which is accessible on uh crime data
Explorer famar thank you um and um uh it
doesn't uh reflect that my experience in
Portsmouth on the police commission
is uh there is we are we are down at
this point uh we're we're slotted for 70
officers budgeted for 70 officers we uh
last check we had 64 and you know we had
another
a number in the hiring pipeline the
conversations I've had with the uh Chief
the deputy chief and and the captains do
not indicate that uh they're unable to
uh uh investigate crimes or arrest
people because of the uh the the the six
people who aren't there it hasn't
affected uh those kind of services it
affects other kinds of services it means
that the department is spending way more
money uh much to the displeasure of the
city council on overtime so the shifts
are being covered uh the jobs are being
done but we're we're uh working our
officers to the bone with and they're
doing overtime that's the experience in
Portsmith I can't speak for any other
police department representative Stone
though I think that there probably is an
aspect of that in other areas where
there are significant um significant um
Staffing show problems that being said I
I do think that what we are dealing with
is not necessarily A Statewide spiking
crime but a very focused area in
particularly highly populated areas
where there are a need for services and
and there's a lot of people that um are
ryant on public services where you are
seeing these spike in these nuisance
crimes I'm talking about with the the TR
trespassing the shoplifting the things
of that nature and that's why you're
seeing uh actually um the prime sponsor
of the bill in the Senate was from
Manchester so I I think that it it's
evident that while there may not be a
spike in crime there's a there's a
there's a spike in in in the clash
between the two societies I spoke of
that um needs addressing and
unfortunately we won't be able to
address it fully with criminal justice
because that's not what we should do um
representative Murray
um you know I don't want to start a
whole back and forth on this because I
don't know you know how productive it is
and I know we're all trying our best to
come up with Solutions here but I'm I'm
really just stuck on this houseless
people and the trespassing thing even if
we made it like trespassing on public
property instead of private property or
something like that but I think when
we're talking about victims like these
people are are victims too they're
victims of society I've had um I was
lucky enough to buy my first house with
my husband last last year and since that
time I've had three different friends
stay with me who because they became
houseless who had never experienced
houselessness before because the state
of our economy is just crazy right now
you know people can't afford to live and
people who have never been in these
situations before are now becoming
houseless and I think that's why we're
seeing you know an expanse in this area
if anything is because people simply
can't afford to live so for example one
of my friends had a child and was living
in her car you know to arrest her and
you know charge her with trespassing put
her on electronic monitoring all the
stuff like how is that going to solve
anything with a young mom trying to take
care of her and her child and I know we
can't as a committee address um all the
social side and like Services side of
these things but I also want to keep us
from making the situation worse for some
of these people and I think we should
try as hard as we can to like thread the
needle and figure out you know the
issues where like shoplifting there's a
clear you know victim that someone is
being you know harmed in that case um
with uh trespassing and no there
definitely can be too but I just think
it's either not as severe or not like as
often like in Manchester it's often
people staying in the park you know and
that's yeah and that's not harming
anyone and I also you know am the reper
who lives in Manchester I also work
downtown in Manchester I bartend at
night it's not a problem for me to come
into my shift and be like persons you
know who spent the night in the doorway
please move we're opening now no big
deal here's some water get on your way
at the end of the night give them
leftover food move on with my day like
that's not I'm not a victim in that
situation because someone the you know
best way they can get out of the cold to
sleep in our doorway at night and so I
just really want us to like think about
how we cannot make the situation worse
in the way we're trying to address this
despite the fact that we can't actually
always provide the solution in this
committee and I know it's a tricky B
balance but I'm just trying to bring
like that human centered approach here
someone who has again like a lot of
friends who have become houseless over
the past year thank you I think that's a
very good point to oh and I was about to
ask the captain but he left um the
number of arrests that are rearrests for
um trespassing did you want to add not
to that point actually something that's
occurred to me as I've been sitting here
in terms of the legislation I think that
we talked about or you've talked about
you know providing them with information
about Services I think also though I
think they're going to have to be
defendants are going to need to be
provided with information about
electronic monitoring before they make
that decision and so I do think that
that should be part of the legislation
that they'll be required to be informed
uh what the expectations are if there's
potential costs associated and then you
know I certainly agree with Professor
sher's thoughts about the availability
of this data to law enforcement um and
you know if that's potentially going to
be subject to a search warrant which I I
don't agree with but if that would
happen then I think they need to be
notified of that before they make the
decision so I I think that should be
required that they are informed of those
rights and and sign off on it I I agree
that there will be a uh some type of a
form that says if by accepting this I
understand ABC D D um and as I told the
professor I'm have no contemplation of
putting in there that this is accessible
by search warrants one way or the other
but like any data that's available
anywhere the police can apply for a
search warrant whether or not the court
grants it is a decision up to the court
I could we could say we're going to Bar
it um but in that case I could be
causing another harm later where it
could end up being the key to a murder
case that I don't I don't want to get
into that right now um and I would
rather let the courts decide whether or
not that's properly accessible or not
sure but in terms of notification to the
defendant I think he would need to be
notified that that's at least a
potential yeah um before he agrees yeah
I agree yeah okay so at this point I
think we've discussed this um enough and
I'm going to ask for again like I did
yesterday an informal vote so that we
can send this language um May I address
the committee very shortly yes okay um
first representative uh prad when
someone is arrested they're giving uh
please stick around I have a question
for um
you get something called what you need
to know and it lists the charge the your
court date Court location gives you
information about a bail commissioner
your and your right to an attorney in
addition you're given a copy of the bail
order which is your legal promise to
show up your legal promise to abide by
the conditions of bail and it is your
release document okay so the people when
they leave they'll sometimes ask am I
going to get a notification here it is
they're they are
informed it seems to me uh that we have
this elaborate
Machinery uh that is
unnecessary uh as before I develop that
point uh there's a huge difference
between electronic monitoring for
um misdemeanor and for an aggravated
felonius assault I think we you need to
separate here's why this Machinery
sounds good so did felonies first and we
know what happened to it I live in the
world I don't see this
particularly
working um where where I'm going is
the right now I signed arrest warrant
for people who bail jump okay when do
they get picked up there's the people
live in town they live neighboring
communities there some of them athu and
we can't reach them and the police sort
of I I they're they're loaded with work
they don't go after these people the way
they usually get pulled in is if they
have another they're
caught speeding and they run the car
then they see they out a bail J then
they bring them in but it's it's I can't
say they never go to the house to get
them but it's
exceptional so what I'm S I believe this
is a problem that needs to be handled at
a higher level mainly post trial not
pre-trial as important and essential as
pre-trial is I'm wholeheartedly for that
but I'm a narrowing and here's where I'm
going with why I want to ask uh
Professor sherff my uh understanding is
correct if you are arrested and on this
what you need to know there's an RSA I
wish I had one with it's in the car it
says if you're arrested on a a second
time when you're on bail they don't need
a bail commissioner they Polie have the
the unilateral right to take you to jail
period and you see a judge so my
solution is I don't understand I really
I don't see it in my jurisdiction the
jurisdiction in which I work of this one
after the the I don't get that I don't
see it and it's up the second time they
go to jail period well obviously that's
not correct we heard the testimony from
the Manchester police chief we heard the
testimony from uh several Chiefs who
said that they have a revolving door of
people coming in getting arrested be
released res so Salem may be different
but Manchester certainly not I'm going
hold on when this revolving door it's
not being done by bail commission why
aren't they being seen by a judge and
moved up in the process there's
something very loose about the way all
of this is being portrayed and I
challenge you to think about this in
revolving door who's doing this
revolving door why don't they see it the
second time if I see somebody if I as if
it's a completely different crime which
I almost never see if it's a second time
you don't have to call me if you want me
to come in I can set a bail on this
person it's your option but you don't
and the police know it at least my
police know they can go so there's
something very um how can I deny their
experience but there's something IL
defined ill administered here because
they should be before a judge and maybe
the judge is the revolving door I don't
know but I see this as an elaborate
Machinery that's unnecessary and that's
where I am thank you um to be clear the
statute allows for people to be released
um innumerable times on on personal
recognizance well I would well almost I
wouldn't put it that way uh the the the
statute that's in place now RSA
5972 Roman numeral 3C reads like this
if there is probable cause to believe
it's entitled failure of a person to
abide by previous bail conditions
getting arrested again is that failure
if there is probable cause to believe
that while on release pending resolution
of a previous offense the person
committed a felony a Class A misdemeanor
or driving or operating while impaired
there shall be a rebuttable presumption
that the person will not abide by a
condition that the person not commit a
new offense uh the court shall not
impose a financial condition that will
result in the pre-trial Detention of the
person so as a result of that Financial
condition unless the court determines by
clear and convincing evidence after a
hearing that no reasonable alternative
or combination of conditions will assure
that the person will not commit a new
offense so therein I think is the
problem well not the problem but what
the Gap we're talking about is that that
all contemplates once you get to the
judge that does not contemplate what the
bail commissioner should do it says the
court shall assume well my understanding
of the bail commissioner statute it
gives the bail commissioner all the
authority a judge has in terms of
setting bail so this applies to a bail
commissioner now in terms of improvement
you know uh then uh it uh instead of
saying the court shall not impose and
and talking about the court the court or
bail you know it could be more explicit
the court or bail commissioner if we add
magistrates to this the court or bail
commissioner or magistrate that would
make it more clear uh and I think that's
part of the issue with some bail
Commissioners in terms of training I
don't think there's a full appreciation
of the scope of their powers um and
that's a a training issue I think that
this committee has talked about yeah
okay thank you okay okay um that
concludes discussion um at this point I
would ask for a um for a non-binding
just is just a vote to send this
language over to OS um everyone in favor
of the following if someone is arrested
while on bail the first time they have
an option to wear uh electronic
monitoring or they are held on the
second time they are arrested while on
bail they are held um to see the judge
is could I see a hands of everyone in
favor of that language
please with with the exception of
possibly homeless
people on certain properties thank thank
you and um and I think that was it
right what I feel like d weigi that was
it seems like we talked awful lot about
yes sir one of the things I thought did
we did we agree uh
what that one of the options also would
be releasing someone under PR bail um
with the pre-trial Intervention Program
being required as a baill uh as a
condition of Bill we talked about it but
there was no pre-trial Intervention
Program available that's if Bill if
Avail where they are available
or um I don't believe that we discussed
it yeah it would be the funding of that
um go ahead representative I definitely
think that would money the waters and
what we're trying to accomplish here you
can't really mandate something that
doesn't exist in a particular County and
we don't know exactly what services they
have I think that would be something
properly addressed in the in the
commission when they form the Statewide
I don't see how how um we could well if
you if you have a county you know like
Treasure County where they actually do
have you know pretty involved um pre-out
programs that are available I mean one
of the ways we could write it is just
say if if available so it would be an
option if the programs are available if
they are not available it wouldn't be an
option what would be the yeah but I
guess what I'm asking is what would be
the you'd have to be much more narrow
okay pre-trial Services what will they
contain what what this is in the
situation you know again of um I know
we're kind of combining things but the
again a nuisance arrest so you've got
somebody who has an obvious problem you
know whether it's um it's uh it's drug
addition addiction mental health issues
um chronic
homelessness uh and they are arrested
twice let's say for criminal trespassing
or shouting at people on the street or
whatever it is that they get arrested
for um it would it would provide the
option to divert them to some type of a
program if I would agree that the that
the Court we can say that the court has
the option but I want them to see the
judge so if if the judge says okay you
may be released um if you go to
pre-trial
services that that would be fine but to
put that on the baill commissioner say
okay you have to hook up with free-
trial Services somehow um it's just it
it's there's too many moving parts that
I can think of that how we would ensure
that representative Stone yeah just a
followup if the individual de Clines to
be released that individual still has to
be seen before a judge yeah so it's not
a long span of time I would imagine it
be 24 hours if they're held in no one
we're talking about would be held longer
than that short period of time anyway so
at which point the judge could say I'm
going to release you to pre-trial
Services we're not mandating they the
judge hold people just the bail
commissioner till they get to the judge
which can be no more than 24 hours so
keeping that simple I think is the best
way to go instead of trying to add all
this extra language and possibly
programs don't exist in certain areas
yeah I I just think that it's too much
to happen in the short period of time
until looking to see the judge anyway
that where the judge would actually send
them to pre trial if it exists okay um
but we're going to continue um some of
the discussions as we craft the langage
to send over to OS the next time we meet
we were going to have language on what
we discussed yesterday and what we
discussed today to have a formal vote of
the subcomittee and we will promptly
move into the main meet of the matter um
with regard to the
um the magistrate issue we've discussed
and the crimes that the Senate wants
included in how we are going to about
addressing that so next week is going to
be very busy um watch we may have to add
a day I'm not sure yet I know nobody
likes that but we're coming up on the
deadline to get this stuff over to the
clerk's office so weay today I'm not
prepared to do any of that um but I do I
am going to stay today just to type this
and send it over to LS so that's going
to be enough okay yes sir if uh we added
a day would that be Wednesday do you
think I'm not sure yet um did you have a
conflict uh not necessarily but as far
back as we could know the day that great
I I'm probably going to end up ending
I'll probably be out of state on Monday
that's I'm probably going to end adding
a day the following week as we come into
the final week okay rather than next
week so U matter of fact is everyone is
available I'm thinking about changing
Wednesday Thursday for Wednesday next
week because I have another uh U
commitment for the legislature is anyone
available next Wednesday or not
available next Wednesday we do have
another uh we have the 470 subcommittee
meeting at 10 o'cl on Wednesday how long
does that usually last um that's
probably going to go about an hour and a
half okay so we may I may end up having
to move us to an afternoon on Wednesday
like a one o'clock okay
um we usually only we'd only probably be
meeting for an hour to vote on that um
Friday would be longer though I'll let
you all know watch your emails okay
anything
else okay thank you see you all next
week